cystic fibrosis is a hereditary disease
that affects thousands of people each
year
it causes mucus to build up in the lungs
leaving affected patients more
vulnerable to infection than healthy
people patients like Gary are thankful
for medications containing the
aminoglycoside tobramycin they help to
combat his respiratory system infections
caused by the bacteria of Pseudomonas
aeruginosa
however the misuse of these medications
can make them less effective gary was
prescribed toby an inhaled medication
containing tobramycin gary only takes
toby when he is feeling sick not
according to his prescription let's take
a closer look at how this affects Toby's
effectiveness here are 3 Pseudomonas
aeruginosa each one is represented as a
little house and here's Toby and his
molecular form toby helps Gary eliminate
the bacteria by attacking the rapa somes
normal ribosomes have two subunits and
create protein through translation a
small 30s subunit binds to a strand of
mRNA routing it to the larger 50s
subunit the larger subunit fixes the
complementary tRNAs and they're attached
amino acids to create a polypeptide
chain
Toby binds to the 30s subunit
interrupting translation the resulting
protein is either terminated early or
not proof-read without the correct
proteins the bacteria eventually die
sometimes toby isn't able to do his job
some bacteria produce enzymes that
modify amino glycosides by acetylation
phosphorylation or a generation this
prevents Toby from binding to the
ribosomes and inhibiting protein
production these resistant bacteria are
able to reproduce and create new
generations of resistant bacteria making
Toby useless don't be like Garry finish
your antibiotics use them according to
your prescriptions and don't use them
when you don't have to for more
information about how to combat
antibiotic resistance and stay healthy
visit the PDB website
[Music]